here here's here's angel's the outfield
for you so my mom had just passed away
and i was just
devastated back in 1993.
i was back home for a couple months i
was like i want to keep doing this i
just kind of moved to hollywood i did a
few mini series and stuff and things
were starting to cook
and after that i was just devastated and
then i came out to hollywood because
they were auditioning for this movie
angels in the outfield and it's funny
uh eisenhower's favorite film of all
time was the original angels in the
field this little tidbit there
nice nice so you know when i auditioned
for it in in the script it says whit
bass throws pitch
and i told the director you know i play
college baseball you know i've got some
ideas i want to make this guy really
quirky and and different and such and
he's like great perfect you get the part
and because i came with such confidence
so
um
during uh they had like a baseball boot
camp and you know it was carny lanford
and all these sex pro guys you know
after a couple days of boot camp like
you know you can just you don't have to
be here you can just you know take the
week off and do whatever you want but we
got to work these guys you know for
baseball because it's not a very good
baseball player might be great
so i went back to my hotel room and
every day i would look in the mirror and
try to figure out the goofiest things
for this character
and so i came up with the idea of um and
i went to the director and there's tens
of thousands of fans in the stadium
in oakland i said it's my first shot
first shot of the moon first shot of a
movie
any movie and i said look if give me a
favor can you follow me with the camera
i'm going to come in from you know from
first base i'm going to do something
going into the mound and he looks at me
like i have nine heads he's like what
can just trust me there's one tape it's
only just one take but i've got this
great idea been working out in my hotel
room for the last week
and bill dear bless his soul today
okay boys follow me with the camera and
i work this this thing sliding in my in
my hotel room so i i would run in from
first base slide into the pitcher's
mound circle the mound a few times grab
the rosin bag do this crazy stuff and
throw the first pitch and the place went
bonkers just lost and bill's like you
can do anything you want in your
afternoon since then i've worked in a
few movies with bill what is this stupid
what
that i've had since i was a kid that my
mom instilled in me there's no one like
you neil there's no one like you you
know as a kid i had dyslexia i had a
lisp i had all these impediments against
me you know you know and and to to to
have this kind of confidence that my mom
instilled in me you know was you know
amazing and then you know when i met
ravine 2000 you know i finally had
someone you know a woman in my my corner
again and still infusing that confidence
in me and it's just kept going but i've
been blessed that i've had two women
mentors in my life that have always kind
of
pressed me to be the best that i could
be and because of that i have this dumb
confidence and and i can get up in front
of thousands of people and speak and
you know and do these things because you
know that that's the messages that i
have and who i am and what i stand for
is you know it's i guess it's kind of
unique and it's just
it's me and have you ever had a director
call you like spielberg or anybody like
that just
you just nodded your head spielberg
called you
yeah okay well one of the best calls
steven ever made to me
was uh we had just done
a pilot called uh boomtown you know i
just did vanderbrothers and i just did
uh
a minority report
and
it was supposed to be jimmy smith was
supposed to play this hispanic
lover type guy on boomtown and he
dropped out in the 11th hour and stephen
said what about neil mcdonough and
uh they called me and i auditioned for
it i got the part and pilot went great
it was an awesome show
and we're in montreal
doing timeline uh and i still didn't
didn't have a whole lot of money at the
time and revay and i went into this
really high-end jewelry store looking at
you know
wedding rings
and she saw one and she said this is the
one i really wanted i was like oh my
gosh it's so expensive oh my gosh i'll
never be able to afford this what am i
gonna do what am i gonna do
hi stephen hey neil what are you doing
right now i'm in the jewelry shop
looking for a ring for her bed he goes
buy her one the size of texas because
boom town just got picked up for a full
season
okay thank you bye
what he called you
and that was it